wir sind zurzeit in einer ausgesprochen
guten situation die zahlen sinken die
infektionszahlen die belegung der
krankenhäuser sind wir ärzte haben jetzt
die verpflichtung dafür zu sorgen dass
das durch den herbst hindurch trägt
unsere aufgabe ist es auch die
bevölkerung darauf vorzubereiten was
passieren kann wenn wir glück haben dass
hier gar nichts dann sind wir alle
zufrieden haben wir als ärzte auf unsere
aufgabe bestens erfüllt aber wir müssen
einfach davor warnen dass es aus dem
normalen virus geschehen heraus
möglichkeiten gibt dass sich die
situation im herbst wieder verschlimmert
und dann haben wir wieder die politische
diskussion damit haben wir erzeugen ist
gar nichts zu tun die politische
diskussion kontakt beschränkungen masken
pflicht für dich die dann sehr wäre und
auch noch mal wieder über die
impfpflicht deswegen sagen wir wollten
impfen impfen impfen testen testen
testen und beim testen vor allem auch
checken ob da neue variationen neue
mutationen wieder vorkommen aber wir
wissen eines wer geimpft ist wer drei
mal geimpft es am besten er hat heute
sein risiko an der erkrankung zu
versterben um 99% hier sind dass uns
eine fantastische zahl die gibt es und
jetzt nicht bei der grippeimpfung kann
und es nur 50 prozent gibt es bei
bestimmten vorgängen bei denen bei denen
das virus sich nicht verändert wie zum
beispiel masern aber wer das tut der hat
eine gute chance und deswegen müssen wir
die impf kampagne forcieren wir müssen
das testen machen und wir müssen hoffen
dass es nicht zu einer variation und
mutation kommt da gibt's dann so mal
läuten die laufen rum und behaupten dass
sich im laufe von mutationen die virus
qualität als vereinfacht erleichtert ist
falsch da steht dann merkt euch steht im
lehrbuch das ist ein absoluter -
fertiger uns sehen und das wird immer
wiederholt lesen sie einfach mal die
arbeiten dazu also nicht lehrbücher
ausgetragen jahrhundert und dann werden
sie die fakten zur kenntnis nehmen also
wenn das stimmt was sie sagt ist er
seltsam dass selbst die impfquote
beachten in keiner weise geimpfte
weniger versterben wie ungeimpfte das
ist einfach fakt aber ist will ich will
ja fast eine frage ich will ja fast
gewinnen das geschenk geschenk ich will
aufs anderes geschenk danke dann ich
arbeite in wissenschaftlichen leitlinien
das sitzen experten zusammen ag
bestimmte regeln eingehalten und dann
muss man einfach das pferd von vorne und
nicht von hier aufzunehmen wir müssen
wir überlegen was ist denn eigentlich
das ziel der ganzen maßnahmen was war
denn das ziel gewesen das war doch die
überlastung der krankenhäuser zu
verhindern und wir wissen doch dass das
niemals der fall war dass die
überlastete dran ist steht seit april 19
2021 auf der homepage des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums da steht
die leipzig untersuchung der
belegungssituation
2020 wortwörtlich kann der zuschauer
auch nachprüfen da steht es war noch nie
so eine tiefe belegung in den
krankenhäusern historisch unterbelegt
auch die intensivabteilung
16 prozent weniger belegung im vergleich
zu 2009/10 es waren das war die pandemie
die leeren betten und die krankenhäuser
transportiert jetzt kommt aber die preis
war jetzt kommt die
191 welt nicht eindeutig sehen war ein
hacker aus dem hut sein inhalt jetzt
kommt die warnung nicht reden
jetzt kommt die wichtigste zahl der
gesamten corona krise jetzt kommt die
wichtigste teil und ich möchte gern
wissen ob sie die kennen wie viel
prozent dieser schon unterbelegung hat
in den krankenhäusern die diagnose
kurven zu bekommen 4 prozent wissen sie
es für hier keine statistik herr amthor
sie beschließen infektionsschutz
gesetzlich beschließen
sie haben dax unterstützt und auch
kennen den sie gemeinsam kennen sie
kennen die wichtigste zahl nicht die die
einfach zeigt ob wir ein großes problem
hatten oder nicht kennen sie die tat
also diese zahl ist völlig bedeutungslos
weil die fakt ist dass wir heute den
menschen die in den intensivstationen
gearbeitet haben über ein pflege bonus
reden weil die sind am ende das ist ein
pflege jüdischer staffelhighlight ich
habe ja doch auch ausreden dass ich will
wissen ob sie die zahlten sie können
ich hätte aber die nicht sagen nach
einer rede über die wichtigsten zahlen
zu wenig zu hören
über ein jahr mit nennen ist das kalt
was andere sagen nein das ist ja das
stimmt auch nicht sagen leben einmal die
zahl herr frank 2 prozent und die
kleinen prozent was ist die quelle
dieser zahlen die kennen sie nicht das
ist die auftrag des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums
an das leipziger institut seit einem
jahr steht die zahl auf der homepage 2
prozent im schnitt und offensiv dreieck
firma 4% wo ist denn da das problem also
dass sie mir das jetzt sagen das problem
ist darin dass wir in den intensiv dazu
wir haben ein intensiv register der ddr
wissen sie vielleicht dass wir zeitweise
am obersten rande der berliner und nicht
die ganze zeit nicht ein ganzes jahr
hindurch aber zeitweise und das wird
deswegen die bundeswehr geholt haben
womit meditec flugzeugen menschen
innerhalb deutschlands von einer
intensiven das verrechnen und so vor der
unabhängig ist das noch nie passiert mit
der verlegung von patienten das ist
nicht sicher wie heute haben wir haben
mit den magic fliegern bei ebola leute
aus dem ebola regionen in afrika nach
deutschland während das nicht
widersprechen intensivbetten abgebaut in
deutschland sie das sagen sie nicht
sprechen und ich brachte in den
playstation zahlen des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums
es war nie ein problem es gibt immer
punktuell überbelegungen es gab immer
freie betten es steht wortwörtlich herr
montgomery und sie kenne das nicht sie
mich schön eine panik im herbst und sie
dass die sehnlich ein faktencheck ja ja
sag ich erhebe her und dann zeigen wir
dass
solche sie also sie können mich gerne
hört zahl stimmt bestimmt ob die
rückschlüsse daraus richtig sind ist die
nächste frage wenn man jetzt mal das
bescheidene bild eines nicht mediziner
sondern eines wahlkreisabgeordneten
sieht es genau das so wie es herr
montgomery beschrieben hat wir haben
über den jahreswechsel letztes jahr das
erste mal erlebt dass ein kleines
bescheidenes krankenhaus in meiner
heimatstadt ueckermünder aus der
universitätsmedizin greifswald verlegt
werden musste als erste mal in der
geschichte weil maximalversorger
universitätskliniken voll waren in den
wenn sie station meine kleine regionale
krankenhäuser alle mieter hat mal ein
personalproblem
ersatzlosen auch ohne das ist doch
völlig quer vor
2001 also es ist wahnsinn dass ich leute
ja eher regel zumindest sollte man das
kann natürlich sein dass alle anderen
blöd sind und diese eine schlüsselzahl
nicht erkannt haben ich höre jetzt mal
sagen es spricht viel dafür dass man die
von herrn montgomery angeführten zahlen
eben auch ernst nimmt und ich gucke mir
das gerne an aber die eine zauber zahl
die jetzt sozusagen die mehrzahl der
wissenschaft in sich zusammenfallen
lässt das finde ich dann doch sehr
überrascht ist die realität ohne gerede
über die realität sie reden über
modellrechnungen ich rede über die
messungen der kogit patienten in den
deutschen krankenhäusern und die war bei
unterbelegung 2 prozent im schnitt und
das ist fakt und davon muss man ausgehen
und deswegen ist die ganze panikmache
durch diese zahl wieder lieber wenn wir
das läuft schon mit der zahl waren um
jetzt herr fragen wissen wer ein glas
wegbleiben realität in eine spannende
frage bleibt aber natürlich und die
möchte ich gerne herr amt vorstellen ob
man nicht doch man merkt ja redebedarf
es da in der bevölkerung braucht man
vielleicht ein crooner
untersuchungsausschuss wo genau alles
mal durchdekliniert und durch wir haben
ein corona begleit gremium eingesetzt
dass ich genau mit diesen fragen
beschäftigt richtig ist und das muss man
schon mal sagen die politische
diskussion darum ist ja nicht beendet es
war richtig dass die impfpflicht keinen
halt machen wir müssen jetzt aber schon
sehen und das war auch heute bei uns ein
thema im innenausschuss aber natürlich
auch gefragt wie bereitet man sich denn
jetzt auf den herbst vor was sind die
überlegung und wir haben ja sehr gesagt
man muss damit man eben fakten und
evidenzbasiert entscheidet auch wissen
was die lage ist wir haben ja gefordert
dass wir über das imwf register zum
beispiel mal reden die bundesregierung
schläft macht nichts also die haben ja
auf den letzten metern damit scholz und
lauterbach noch ihre mehrheit kriegen
haben sie haben gesagt sie sind auch für
nimke vista vorbereitet wird jetzt gar
nichts und ich sehe es auch dass die
bundesregierung das jetzt einfach laufen
lässt und dann kommt nachher die
überraschung dass man nicht vorbereitet
war das ist jetzt die zeit dafür aber es
muss eben auch ein blick nach vorne
gehen und die rückspiegel diskussionen
sie jetzt kommt ihre habe der rückseite
findet in haft peter ist sie sind nun
fertig ich bin sehr auf den namen merken
nicht warum ich bin
also ich bin es auf der homepage des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums ja ja auf
seite 4 leipzig analyse
das mindeste unter berücksichtigung
wurde wurde die belegung minus 16
prozent zurückgefahren auch auf intensiv
dies berücksichtigt bereits sie
versuchen so weiter im jahresschnitt die
für die belegung 2 prozent aller betten
und 4 prozent aller intensivbetten für
die diagnose sowie das ist wie das ist
absolut der realität von menschen die
man im krankenhaus waren zu denen ich
gehöre die sich das mal angeguckt haben
sie gesehen haben was unsere mitarbeiter
dort arbeiten was sie leisten was sie
jeden tag leisten weswegen wir ihnen am
anfang vom abt vom vom balkon aus
applaudiert haben und jetzt am ende ein
pflege bonus zahlt man streiten kann und
eben nicht in den hintern tritt und ach
quatsch aber ganz nicht versucht man ja
wirklich diesen menschen auch mehr
schutz zu geben für sich selber und auch
für ihre patienten vor allem natürlich
vorbei die die zwei werden sie nachher
an alle hier teilen wir werden alle rum
schenken dann macht hermann gommel
nochmal den faktencheck abenteuer auch
ich gucke mir auch an